in 2010 nokia's factory near chennai
india was among the largest in the world
thousands of workers most of whom were
women churned out over 15 million phones
per month
nokia was a shining example of the kind
of success that india wanted with
manufacturing but in 2014
the plant suddenly had to shutter why
because of a tax dispute mobile phone
making major nokia shut down its largest
plant at tamlaj street pelham
making over 8 000 workers jobless
the dispute was over a 1.5 billion tax
demand slapped on retroactively by
authorities for alleged owed taxes
essentially this factory became a ghost
town eventually nokia and the indian
government would settle but the damage
was done
and there are other examples too british
companies vodafone
and cairn energy
along with at least 17 other companies
were all involved in disputes
and while this has been happening prime
minister narendra modi has been trying
to attract foreign investment
making india
has become the biggest brand
that india have ever created
the bureaucracy can often go against
whatever it is that the political class
is expressly trying to achieve
while india might be securing jobs for
its highly skilled elite complicated
uncertain taxes have pushed most foreign
companies in need of cheap labor towards
china
that's costing the economy an estimated
140 billion dollars a year
they've been saying they're open to the
rest of the world but you know there's
still a lot of protectionist barriers in
doing business with india
to follow in china's footsteps and reach
the government's goal of being a 5
trillion economy by 2025
india needs to create a model which
succeeds both at home and abroad
for hundreds of years the indian
subcontinent was among the richest
places on earth accounting for an
estimated 25 percent of global trade
then came the british
essentially britain
kept india as a supplier of raw
materials for its own factories
and as a market
for what those factories produced
it's estimated that in today's money
great britain extracted 45 trillion
dollars from india
fast forward to the late 1940s india
gained independence to form a
multi-party democratic system of
government
and across the border the chinese
communist party came into power to form
the people's republic of china
[Music]
suspicious of the west and lacking in
things they could sell to the world both
took a page out of the soviet union's
economic playbook turning the countries
inward
there was a sense that they could of
course feed themselves and sustain
themselves china wasn't the only economy
to look inward but generally speaking
the sense of looking inward was
considered to have been a big
contributor to the depression in the 30s
in the case of india and china these
centrally planned economies ultimately
didn't work
but while their economies largely stood
still a select few neighbouring
economies boomed
they became known as east asian tigers
hong kong singapore taiwan and south
korea they were known as economic wonder
childs from the 1960s onwards they
boomed in the post-war period they had
cheap labor
they had industrial know-how and they
embraced technology
so all of the toys and clothes and
trinkets that the western world was
buying in the 60s and 70s and 80s all of
that was made in these tiger economies
it was an economic model that was an
envy of the world but there's no doubt
when it comes to the ultimate model for
china they have looked to singapore
chinese officials flooded into singapore
routinely to visit first study and to
learn from singaporean know-how
obviously the scale doesn't compare but
what china saw in singapore they liked
there was that degree of
authoritarianism there was that degree
of anti-corruption there was of course
that sense of efficiency and
productivity and this industrial and
export-led model china liked it and they
looked to singapore and they embraced a
lot of it
in 1978 deng xiaoping announced the open
door policy to allow foreign companies
to set up in china
their biggest asset a seemingly
limitless low-skilled workforce that
could fill large factories with laborers
they had huge workforces huge industrial
facilities and they were hungry for
foreign capital foreign know-how and
foreign investment and one of those
ingredients were mixed together what you
saw was a great shift of global
manufacturing into china especially of
low-end goods toys plastic linens
trinkets all of that shifted to china
and we saw an explosive manufacturing
boom in the 80s and in the 90s
especially china averaged 10 growth per
year in the year since it opened in 1978
almost 800 million people have been
pulled out of poverty in china since the
great reopening
starting in the mid 80s and then in a
big way after 1991 india also opened its
doors
although not normally thought of as an
exporting powerhouse india's export
growth has been the third best in the
world behind china and vietnam
that
has been a big puzzle
because
yes india is an exporting success story
but what is it that india actually makes
and exports
instead of low-end manufacturing such as
trinkets and textiles made by china and
other east asian tigers the country is
uniquely focused on high skilled
manufacturing and services such as
software business process outsourcing
and engineering goods
this has created a bias in jobs and
opportunities for a relatively small
english-speaking well-educated minority
but those previously left behind are
getting another shot thanks to
technology
to give you an example
a seller who used to have a brand or
used to have a product which was limited
to one district or one city had no idea
how to expand the distribution and reach
to 4000 miles away from their home city
but because of the digitization of
economy a seller can now dream big
they can think about becoming an
indian large entrepreneur versus
becoming an entrepreneur only for that
particular city
with the help of apps like udan indian
entrepreneurs are getting access to tens
of millions of retailers catering to 1.3
billion consumers
and the mom and pop shop selling these
products known as karana stores can make
better purchases faster and receive
credit they would otherwise struggle to
get
them payment baby
before the platform existed they will
rely on multiple sources they will rely
on local distributors they have to do
multiple price negotiations because
every time they have to do multiple
deals
they will have to find multiple lenders
to provide them then they will need to
coordinate the transportation to get the
goods or to make sure that they are
available in their store to receive the
goods
access to smartphones and cheap data is
transforming industries that have been
stagnant for a long time
it's enticing new entrepreneurs to
produce and sell products with money
pouring in from investors in silicon
valley hoping for a piece of the
industry
local manufacturing boost will really
help because you will see
a lot more indian brands uh dominating
the shells in india and and overseas and
this the whole digital economy and
internet is providing that platform
to give that access to information
access to product access to capital
access to credit
and that's really helping our economy
another economic boost is coming in the
form of generous government subsidies to
makers of everything from electric cars
to textiles
and as these industries grow india can
tap into its most obvious advantage
its booming population
set to surpass china over the next
decade
now the tide has turned
and the chinese population from here on
is
only going to become older the median
population age in india is still below
30 and india still probably has around
three decades before its population two
is considered old now that's three
decades a wonderful opportunity
if india plays its cards right 500
million people will enter the middle
income class over the next decade
this will be the largest growth into the
middle class anywhere in the world
fueling massive domestic demand
as the middle class grows the purchasing
power will come so india definitely has
a story to tell the world that it is
ready to fill the gap that is going to
be left behind
by china
as two things happen
one as china wants
to move out of low value added low
skilled
markets
and as the economic estrangement between
beijing and washington grows
india has a role to fill
for america beach
but choosing india over countries like
vietnam still has many disadvantages
although almost every industry is now
open to foreign investment import
tariffs have been increasing since 2018
and the import process remains
convoluted and time-consuming a drag on
today's interconnected global supply
chains
the problem is at the level of customs
and the level of disputes with the with
the customs authorities on whether
something is chargeable so the indian
government is involved in just too many
tax disputes with its private sector
income tax dispute import duty disputes
gst disputes now
modi's make in india campaign is
threatening a return to the failed
socialist model of self-reliance
something that might only benefit a
select group of politically connected
firms
in india politicians do
have to go and win elections every five
years
and these are very expensive elections
and
they have to be fought
with corporate donations
so which means that
in india the political class
has to strike a balance
in terms of how it deals with the
private sector
but high tariffs and other trade
barriers might restrict make in india to
just make for india
when the much larger opportunity is
making things for the world
it's simply not possible to become an
exporting powerhouse just by yourself
without importing anything from anybody
just to give you an example india is a
big exporter of human hair
india's tradition of sacrificing hair at
temples and the practice of saving and
collecting hair from individual
households means that it's become the
world's largest supplier of human hair
the majority gets exported for
manufacturing into
wigs
mannequins
and also other extension products and
made into products suitable for
different markets across the world
but before exporting hair companies may
need to add imported products to it in
order to boost value and grow their
business or make it suitable for
international clients the barrier comes
or the challenge comes is when you want
to do value-added products
and the value-added products you need to
import for example keratin glue
a type of protein glue which is made in
italy or china which clients prefer
now
there is another product which is the
imported lace now all of these
importation the process becomes a
challenge
for the smaller ones to grow bigger
confusing taxes and high import tariffs
meant to protect the local market from
foreign competition are major hurdles
companies face when trying to access
overseas markets
it might be sounding crazy to you that
it should be straightforward a chemical
used in a company in china should be
able to be imported but apart from these
importation challenges the import taxes
are generally kept high because they
want to use
the local source
but being the hair industry and it is
not an industry which is well developed
in india
so
for us
import is a big
requirement
whereas the indian government
does not understand that the importation
if they bring it down
will be a long way in terms of making
more further value-added products
although larger companies like raj hair
international have worked with the
government for decades to grow their
business many smaller companies in india
aren't so lucky
it's kept expansion and those crucial
salary jobs at a minimum
i think the statistic is 87
that is the workforce that is either in
agriculture
or is self-employed
or
is casual labor and only about 10
are getting a salary from someone
beyond that 10 of workers earning a
steady salary most live day-to-day with
little to show by way of social security
or medical insurance
you have a country that is teeming with
surplus labor a situation that has been
made infinitely worse by the coronavirus
pandemic
and yet india is not able to demonstrate
to the global community
that it is actually serious about
inviting and then retaining the capital
another major missed opportunity in
india its unemployed female population
[Music]
its female participation rate is among
the lowest in the world
you today have a situation where
bangladesh's
women
in workforce participation rate
is 40 and india's has 20 percent
probably india's has gone down even
further after the coronavirus pandemic
because a lot of women workers
more so than men lost their jobs but
clearly you can't
be
making
progress
at the level at which india wants to
progress if only one-fifth
of half of your population is going to
be you know employed in the workforce
bangladesh which started out as a much
poorer country and established
independence with the help of india has
recently passed india in gdp per capita
bangladesh
is playing to its strengths
it is not
doing high-tech manufacturing
it is essentially doing
low skilled
work
work which is going to absorb
its labor
there are signs this would also work in
india
in the state of tamil nadu where the
nokia factory once ran a number of
manufacturing facilities have been built
in the last decade
now the state has the second highest gdp
and one of the highest female
participation rates in india so clearly
there is a kind of advantage for women
to get into new factories and jobs as
late as probably last month the vola
company has started electric scooters
and the entire manufacturing for the
first time is done by women only women
workers have been mobilized and this
entire factory and manufacturing is done
by women
with the help of robo it is also broken
the myth that in the manufacturing
sector or in the automobile sector you
require male help
although gender and caste inequalities
still exist in india due to differing
education and treatment from a young age
regular secure work may offer a way out
of the cycle now if we take it sector
employment almost
80 percent are all from the so-called
forward caste however welcoming
factories into
india means
there will be infusion of informal
sector workforce
particularly women into manufacturing
sector which is happening and which is
going to bring about what has been
already conceived right from 1990s it
will be a new growth model as well
while the indian government declined to
comment on record they've taken steps to
try and make doing business easier
the goods and services tax or gst
consolidated several state and federal
taxes into just one
and they've stopped allowing retroactive
taxation but the country will need to go
even further if it's to challenge its
biggest competitor
well india is this economy that's always
considered to be the next china but
every time this conversation comes up
it's still the next china one reason by
the way economists say what china did
men at work for india that's called
automation china took advantage of cheap
manual labor and making goods for the
rest of the world now you're we're
moving into a world of rapid automation
so india can throw open its doors and
offer cheap factories to the rest of the
world but in fact a lot of companies and
multinational companies are saying we're
embracing robots we're embracing
automation the model that works for
china may not necessarily be a carbon
copy for india
when you say china it has got a positive
vibe when it comes to manufacturing and
negative vibe in a geopolitical way so
india doesn't want to be the next china
i think so
india will be india at the same time we
will be upskilled and developed in our
own processes but india definitely will
stand by the world to be the next big
manufacturing hub to source and get
products developed for the world market
the focus has to be
on
making the society work for everyone
and to give
everyone a stake now that is something
that east asia did very well
because somehow they managed to
get
a buy in
from the public at large for their
policies
by showing them the way
to a better future
if not for them then for their children
you